Welcome to the Graveyard.
Please, keep your voices down, it’s a very
somber place.
You can feel the sadness here.
The pain.
The things left unsaid.
In that sense, it’s not unlike every other
graveyard all across the world.
But of course, we wouldn’t be covering it
here if it was just any graveyard, would we?
The eagle-eyed among you may notice that we’re
walking through a military cemetery, for starters.
But the people buried here aren’t the martyrs
of any war your history teacher would tell
you about.
The people and entities interred here, fought
their wars in the shadows.
They died in the dark so we could live in
the light.
But who are they?
What is this place?
Who are the people buried here, really?
To find that out, we need to take a step back.
It began in Site-43.
Specifically, Laboratory 37 of Site-43’s
Artificial Intelligence Wing.
Researchers were conducting a series of tests
on a few classified artificial intelligence
anomalies, with the help of a Foundation-made
Artificial Intelligence Construct known as
Marvin.
However, what was meant to be a set of routine
cognition tests turned into a mass containment
breach believed to be coordinated by several
of the rogue AIs involved.
Things went sideways quickly.
The breach resulted in the deaths of three
members of security personnel and it was only
stopped when Marvin and a more benevolent
anomaly worked together to get things back
under control.
While their efforts were valiant, they weren’t
enough to save Marvin himself, who was rendered
inoperable during the breach.
All the copies of the anomalous AIs were neutralized
after testing was complete.
Under the orders of the Site Director, the
remaining materials relating to Marvin and
the neutralized anomalies were left in Laboratory
37.
Things appeared to be returning to normal
until maintenance personnel entered the lab
later that day.
You can undeniably encounter some pretty strange
things inside an SCP Foundation laboratory
- it comes with the territory - but when you
walk into a lab and find yourself standing
in a giant military ceremony, it’s probably
time to contact your supervisors and let them
know.
While those maintenance workers didn’t truly
comprehend what they’d discovered, the Foundation
researchers who got involved shortly afterward
were able to take in the full scope of it:
An ever-expanding extra-dimensional graveyard,
seeming to exist outside of space and time
as we understand it - Which soon became known
to the Foundation as SCP-2783.
The cemetery is believed to currently contain
over a million graves - That’s over double
the mere 400,000 buried at Arlington National
Cemetery.
These graves are meticulously arranged into
huge square grids, each one containing around
90,000 graves apiece.
This would be peculiar enough in its own right,
but things get a whole lot stranger.
Each grave is clearly marked with a name and
an epitaph, but ground-penetrating radar tests
conducted by the Foundation revealed that
only 30% of the graves actually contain human
remains, and the remaining 70% are currently
empty.
And considering that the number of graves
actually seems to be increasing at an arbitrary
rate, it isn’t difficult to draw the conclusion
that some event in the near future is destined
to fill these empty graves.
Perhaps a war like one we’ve never seen
is on the horizon, and SCP-2783 is growing
in preparation to house its teeming casualties.
Death is a funny thing.
It can have varied and unpredictable faces
in the eyes of its beholders, and the great
SCP-2783 cemetery is no exception to this
rule.
It appears slightly different to all who view
it, even when viewing it at the same time.
Factors like climate and weather are dictated
by the place of a person’s origin.
The same goes for the style of the grave markers:
They seem to be culturally specific to a beholder’s
view of what a military grave marker tends
to look like, and the epitaphs are written
in the native language of whoever sees them.
It is a truly universal cemetery.
A place where anyone and everyone can come
and grieve the courageous fallen with equal
understanding and respect.
The Foundation has been able to use GPS tracking
to locate the graveyard’s equivalent on
our planet, tracing it back to an ancient
tomb in Southern Iraq.
There, the Foundation collaborated with the
ORIA - the Organization for the Reclamation
of Islamic Artifacts - to investigate further.
The mission discovered a number of artifacts
belonging to several previously undocumented
pre-Mesopotamian civilizations but failed
to uncover any physical evidence of SCP-2783
at this site.
The cemetery is marked off by a fence that
seems impossible to penetrate.
Those who walk through the door in Laboratory
37 manifest just outside of a gate built into
the fence.
However, any attempt to walk back through
this gate will simply lead to the subject
exiting back through the doors to Laboratory
37.
Thankfully, for any Foundation staff who left
something they actually needed in Laboratory
37, the teleportation does not affect machines,
so remote-controlled robots can still be sent
into the lab.
Shortly after discovering SCP-2783, reconnaissance
teams were sent in to start cataloging the
grave markings.
As concerning information started to pour
in, the Foundation upped the security clearance
on both physical and informational access
to SCP-2783.
Nobody below Level 5 Security Clearance is
able to see the full picture.
So…
What is the full picture?
Well, at the risk of getting assassinated
by the Red Right Hand, let’s take a look
at the few recorded grave markers and see
if we can find out…
Take grave AA-00000, inscribed with the name
“YHWH” - a potential shortening of the
name “Yahweh”, a common alias of the Abrahamic
God.
The epitaph on the grave reads, “He was
vital in Her Construction.
His Design shall prove vital in Her Reconstruction.”
However, there are multiple variants of this
grave, and while all seem to memorialize some
kind of creator deity, there seems to be no
favoritism of any particular type of deity
or any specific religious denomination.
Sightings of variants of this gravestone have
reached the double digits.
Then there’s grave AA-00002, marked Hawwah
Bat Asherah, also known as Eve, the First
Woman.
Her grave marking reads, “The Serpent within
the Library bestowed upon her great Wisdom.
Her loss inspires us all to seek wisdom in
this, the Living World.”
It’s believed by some that Asherah was the
mother of Cain and Able, SCP-073 and SCP-076,
and also spent a period of time as O5-1, wishing
to guide humanity in the right direction.
How about grave AA-00005, marked Lilit Bat
YHWH, also known as SCP-336.
Her epitaph reads “She was loved greatly.
Her beauty will not be forgotten.”
According to Foundation records, Lilith is
a beautiful humanoid woman with reptilian
legs, whose enchanting voice has the power
to induce infertility in women and a combination
of comas and anomalous tumors in men - anomalous
in the sense that they will birth vicious,
deadly chimeras.
Next, grave AA-00006, marked Set Ben Adam.
His epitaph reads, “This graveyard was constructed
under his orders.
When those interred here rise again, it is
under his command they shall fight.”
Set, or Seth, is also known as SCP-4840-A,
a powerful sibling of Cain and Able living
in SCP-4840.
How, when, or why he decided to order the
construction of SCP-2783 is unknown.
Then, grave AB-21917, marked Unknown.
Their epitaph reads, “A Crafter of the FLESH
and a disciple of the Tongueless Speaker.
A worthy foe; his precious moments were expended
on the hordes of the Crimson Crown and so
he is memorialized among the heroes of the
People.”
Radars of the grave showed that the creature
interred within had biology atypical of a
human.
Our interpretation of the epitaph is that
this was a follower of Sarkicism, the worship
of the flesh, who worked with the Church of
the Broken God and the SCP Foundation to fight
against the Scarlet King, and died a hero
as a result.
Next, grave AL-21343 - believed to belong
to Dr. Sophia Light.
Her epitaph reads, “Our Savior and Prophet,
our Staff and Shepard.
The Machine Goddess smiled upon this house,
and even now, those who rest here are tended
to.”
This is one of the many references to the
Machine or Clockwork Goddess, an alternate
title for Mekhane, the deity of the Church
of the Broken God.
Evidence suggests that this cemetery was the
work of the Church and that all who are interred
there were or are going to be aligned with
the Broken God in the struggle against a far
greater threat to us all.
Next, AL-30056, marked Nicholas Flamel, with
the epitaph, “An esteemed scholar who rose
to great heights, but, like Icarus, fell from
great heights.”
While, mythologically, Flamel is believed
to have been an alchemist and creator of the
legendary philosopher’s stone, the Foundation
hasn’t detected any confirmed anomalous
activity connected to him.
Of much greater interest to fans of this channel
we come upon AL-41867, marked Lord Theodore
Thomas Blackwood, his epitaph reading, “His
service to the advancement of Science and
Humanity shall carry on.”
A full-sized human skeleton lays in the grave,
so perhaps Lord Blackwood’s service did
carry on, just in a different body…
Then came the grave of Pvt.
Pyotr Avtukhov, whose epitaph reads, “He
and his fellows have seen the gates of Hell.
Though they do not deserve it, they shall
be first to greet the hordes of the Crimson
Crown when the Gates open.”
Fans of the channel may remember Pvt.
Avtukhov from our coverage of SCP-180: He
was one of the soldiers involved in the horrific
ordeal of the anomalous Battle of Husiatyn
Woods.
Another name you may recognize is the one
carved into grave marker AM-21450: Doctor
Alto Clef.
That’s right, everyone’s favorite lovable
loose cannon.
His epitaph reads, “A loving father.
He gave much more than was demanded of him.”
The variants of his grave also list his other
aliases: Agent Ukulele and Adam El Asem, the
First Man.
The date of his death corresponds with a recorded
near containment breach that resulted in the
deaths of two other members of personnel.
Clef cheats death another day…
For now.
And the most recent grave, AM-21488, was the
grave of Marvin, the AIC that helped save
the day during the containment breach that
opened the portal to SCP-2783.
His epitaph reads, “A machine mind that
gave his life to protect his builders, just
as the Machine Goddess before him.
There will always be a place in Paradise for
those who gave of themselves as he did.”
It’s somewhat heartwarming to know that,
in the eyes of the Clockwork Goddess, a mere
AI can be revered just as much for heroism
as anyone constructed from flesh and blood.
Recorded back in 2017 during a routine search,
Agent Phillip McClean saw thirteen humanoid
entities in funeral garb with an insignia
described as “a white circular shield with
three equidistant protrusions; inside the
shield were three equidistant black arrows
piercing a white circle outlined in black.”
These entities performed what seemed to be
funeral rites, before committing another body
to the dirt below.
The name on the new grave marker was Captain
Kari Michelle Hollis, Mobile Task Force Zeta
9.
Her epitaph read, “She died in a strange
and faraway place with a smile on her face,
a weapon in her hand, and foes on all sides.
She exemplified what all warriors should strive
to be.”
For those of you that can remember our three-part
series on SCP-1730, you may also remember
that Captain Hollis was the brave MTF leader
who sacrificed her own life in the terrible
bowels of Site-13 to turn on the THRESHER
machine, kicking the whole awful place to
another dimension.
Here, her heroic sacrifice can never be forgotten.
While there’s an ominous subtext to a lot
of SCP-2783 - from its predictions of individual
deaths to hints at a bloody war with the Scarlet
King coming down the tracks - there’s something
undeniably beautiful about the idea of this
place.
We share in the mourning and reverence of
the Clockwork Goddess, of heroes great and
small, gone but never forgotten.
In SCP-2783, no act of courage or sacrifice
will ever be lost to time.
Be sure to leave quietly on your way out.
Like we said before, this is a somber place.
Now go check out “SCP 1440 - The Old Man
That Kills All Living Things He Touches”
and “Evil Monster Created by SCP Foundation
SCP-2419 - The Laughing Men” for more SCPs
linked to death, the final frontier!